when you're in a true survival situation
these survival schools will teach you
that you can go three minutes without
air three days without water three weeks
without food that's kind of a rule of
thumb and they'll also teach you that
basically your training survive for 72
hours they should be able to get to you
and rescue you within that time the fact
of the matter is most people who are
going to die out there die within the
first 24 to 48 hours this is an
interesting phenomenon because I get a
lot of them you know have what they need
to survive and yet they don't so there
is it's definitely a phenomenon of
giving up there are people who simply do
give up and it's surprisingly easy to
die out there if you give up so it's
very important to recognize what the
outer limits are but it's also important
to recognize that even though they say
you can go without water for only three
days there are cases where people have
gone for nine days anything's possible
there have been a number of survival
stories that abilities surprised me
because of how bizarre they were or
unusual they were or unlikely that the
person was to survive one in particular
involved a lady named Debbie Kiley who
was on a on a ship that sank in a
hurricane and she in a group amounting
to five people were thrown into a small
boat together on the ocean they had no
water they had no supplies at all and
they drifted for several days this way
and it was very interesting because of
how the people broke down into the
various characters Debbie Kiley was very
determined very organized
she was pretty wobbly at first but she
pulled herself together and with one
other member of the crew was able to
form a pact that they were going to stay
together help each other watch each
other when they slept and not drink
seawater one member of the of the group
was badly injured and was destined to
die anyway the two other members of the
group the captain and the first mate
both were very wobbly from the start
they really had no resolve and they
began drinking seawater and after a time
first one of them said I'm going to the
7-eleven to get some cigarettes and he
got over the side of the boat and swam
away and was eaten by sharks and then
the other one said I'm going for a swim
or something like that and he went over
the side and was eaten by sharks and and
they could hear him hear these people
being eaten by sharks during this whole
episode so it kind of showed how really
some people are destined not to make it
from the very beginning one of the
people who died when the boat was
sinking was screaming we're all gonna
die we're all going to die and I always
say that if that had been in a movie
that would have told you which character
was going to die in the end
and